you've talked to eric once then
uh he has a sense that growth
uh you know like the the the entirety of
the american system is based
on the assumption that we're going to
grow forever the economy is going to
grow forever
do you think uh economic growth will
continue indefinitely
or will we stagnate i've long been in
agreement with eric peter thiel
robert gordon and others that growth has
slowed down
i argued that in my book the great
stagnation appropriately titled
but the last two years i've become much
more optimistic i've seen a lot of
breakthroughs
in green energy and battery technology
mrna vaccines and medicine
is a big deal already it will repair our
gdp and save
millions of lives around the world
there's an anti-malaria vaccine that's
now in stage 3 trial it probably works
crispr to defeat sickle cell anemia
just space area after area after area
there's suddenly the surge of
breakthroughs
i would say many of them rooted in
superior computation
and ultimately moore's law and access to
those computational abilities
so i'm much more optimistic than say the
last time i spoke to eric
i don't know he he moves all the time in
his views i don't know where he's at now
he's not he hasn't gained that's really
interesting so
your little drop of optimism comes from
like there might be a fundamental shift
in the kind of things that computation
has unlocked for us in terms of like it
could be a wellspring of innovation that
can
that uh enables growth for a long time
to come like eric has not
quite connected to the computation
aspect yet
to where it could be a wellspring of
innovation but you're very close to it
in your own work i don't have to tell
you that
the work you're doing would not have
been possible not very long ago
but the question is how much does that
work enable continue
growth for decades to come all their
problems
some version of driverless vehicles will
be a thing i'm not sure when you know
much better than i do
maybe only partially but that too will
be a big deal
well one of the open questions that sort
of the peter thiel's school
uh area of ideas is
how much can be converted to technology
how much
how many parts of our lives can
technology integrate and then innovate
like can it replace uh healthcare okay
you know could can replace the legal
system can replace government
not replace but like you know uh
make it digital and thereby enable
computation to
improve it right that's the open
question
because many aspects of our lives are
still not
really that digitized
there was a new york times symposium in
april which is not long ago and they
asked
the so-called experts when are we going
to get vaccines
and the most optimistic answer was in
four years
yeah and obviously we beat that by a
long mile
so i think people still haven't woken up
you mentioned my tiny drop of optimism
but it's a big drop
of optimism is it a waterfall yet i mean
is it just well here's my pessimism
whenever there are major new
technologies they also tend to be used
for violence directly or indirectly
radio hitler not that he hit people over
the head with radios but
it enabled the rise of various dictators
so the new technologies now whatever
exactly they may be
they're going to cause a lot of trouble
yeah and that's my pessimism not that i
think they're
all going to slow to a trickle when was
the stagnation book
2011 2011. yes
it was the first of these stagnation
books in fact
it's very interesting uh but even then i
said this is temporary
and i was predicting it would be gone in
about 20 years time
i'm not sure that's exactly the right
prediction like 2030 but
i think we're actually going to beat
that so you think
the united states might still be on top
of the world for the rest of the century
in terms of its economic economic growth
impact on the world scientific
innovation all those kinds of things
that's too long to predict but i'm
bullish on america in general
you